[Musique]
pour suivre son plan un million d'arbres
le département de La Réunion a lancé ce
mercredi 6 avril l'opération bois de
quartier au collège plateau-goyave de
saint Louis cette opération qui vise à
planter des espèces indigènes et
endémiques de l'île c'est assorti de la
signature d'une charte d'engagement pour
l'accompagnement pédagogique du collège
c'est donc un vrai parcours éducatif qui
sera travaillé en lien avec
l'établissement pour faire découvrir aux
jeunes pousses le patrimoine naturel de
Lille et les sensibiliser à
l'éco-citoyenneté nos participerons à
l'opération de plantation un million
d'arbres lancés par le département de La
Réunion le collège j'ai investi depuis
plusieurs années dans une démarche de
développement durable nous avons
participé l'année dernière
au concours collège Fleury par le
département et nous avons donc un espace
qui a été lauréat du premier prix de ce
collège fleuri ils sont motivés ils sont
très investis donc on a des écoles qui
fonctionnent depuis plusieurs années
dans l'établissement
on a aussi par rapport à ces
présentations
les différentes classes du collège ont
des noms quatrième bain juin 5e beccrose
donc on a des noms en lien avec la
nature et la flore de la Réunion donc là
qui puisse aussi planter des arbres dont
Yorkers porte ou non donc c'est fait
depuis plusieurs années et à une plus
grande échelle sur le collège de
gattagoya pour cette année ce ne sont
pas moins de 400 plans fournis par la
collectivité dans le cadre de la
dotation biodiversité qui ont été mises
en terre lors de cette matinée par les
collégiens assistés par les agents du
Département donc aujourd'hui c'est une
journée de plantation donc on aménage un
espace dans le collège ça a commencé par
un potager et le projet d'un
amphithéâtre extérieur et au final on a
enrichi le projet avec cette année la
plantation d'arbres endémique donc entre
quatre et 700 arbres vont être plantés
aujourd'hui par tous les élèves de 6e
l'opération bois de quartier dans les
collèges ne s'arrêtera pas là en tout
cet établissement bénéficieront du
dispositif d'ici la fin du mois d'avril
[Musique]